- Welcome to the Yale Council
on Southeast Asian Studies,
virtual Brown Bag Series.
My name is Erik Harms
and I'm the chair of the council.
And it's a pleasure to be
moderating today's discussion
with Nicole CuUnjieng Aboitiz
one of our own recent PhD graduates.
Before we begin,
I need to just note
a few minor bureaucratic
and technical details.
First, I just clicked the record button.
So you should all know that this session
is being recorded for archival purposes.
If you do not wish to be recorded,
please turn off your video camera.
And if you truly do not
wish to be identified
as being a part of this session,
you might also consider
changing your screen name
in the Zoom interface.
Second, we ask that all
participants keep their audio muted,
unless you are a
designated as the speaker,
or if during the question
and answer period,
you have some questions
at the end of the panel presentation.
So just to note,
this is being recorded.
And if you're not interested
in having your image on that thing up,
turn off your camera.
So I'm really excited
to welcome Nicole CuUnjieng Aboitiz today
because it brings back memories
of an intensive Southeast Asia seminar
I taught in the fall of 2013 here at Yale.
Nicole was in that course,
and at the time she was then experimenting
with some of the ideas that would go on
to inform her dissertation research.
And now this book,
"Asian Place Filipino Nation",
which I recommend you all
run out and buy right away.
It's a really fantastic book.
But it's really exciting reading the book
because it brings back
memories of that class.
I distinctly remember learning
so much from her at that time
about our interest in Jose P Laurel,
a graduate of the Yale Law School
who went on to become the president
of the second Republic of the Philippines
right after the Japanese
and Laurel learned a lot from Yale.
But what was so interesting
in what Nicole taught me so much about
was the way in which he
borrowed from the West,
but he never fetishized the West.
And he was much more interested
in what he called mother Asia,
which was cultivated through
his long-term engagement with Japan.
And ever since then,
I've been really impressed
by the breadth of knowledge
that Nicole brings to the table,
not only about the Philippines,
but about all of Southeast Asia.
And it's a kind of breath that recalls
the capacious and comparative
thinking of my colleague,
Ben Kiernan,
who was her advisor.
It's really fascinating .
The first time I ever met Ben
is just having conversations about history
and the way he would
draw in so many threads
from all across the world,
into these weaving these tails,
sometimes just walking
through the new Haven green,
all of these stories would come together
and it's that same kind
of passion for history
and bringing together all these threads
that I see in Nicole's work as well.
And it's that breadth of
thinking that has allowed her
to rethink the intellectual engagements
of the Philippine revolution,
in ways that look to enter Asian exchanges
in a sort of Pan-Asianism
that dissenters the West.
I'm proud to say that
Nicole CuUnjieng Aboitiz
is currently a Research Fellow
at Clare Hall, University of Cambridge,
and is Executive Director of
the Toynbee Prize Foundation.
She's truly one of our most accomplished
graduates of recent years.
So thank you for coming
back to Yale, Nicole,
to our Zoom edition of
the Brown Bag Series.
Everyone, please join me in welcoming her.
And then I'll say a word or two about
the organization of today's discussion.
So just take a moment to welcome Nicole.
Thank you so much for joining us.
Now, the way Nicole and I decided
to run this particular session,
given the Zoom format,
we thought that rather than
a kind of long extended monologue
of the classical book talk style,
that we would engage in
a kind of conversation,
a moderated discussion,
a kind of question and answer
maybe a Southeast Asian studies
version of the daily show
when we have a guest who's
just written a fantastic book.
So I'll start that off
with the first question.
After I've asked a few questions,
I'm sure many of you will
have your own questions.
And so if you start having questions,
just please use the raise
hand function on Zoom,
or just start each shouting
if you can't get my attention
and feel free to interrupt,
because we want this to
be a dynamic conversation
about what's truly a fascinating book.
So, let me start with the
first question for you, Nicole.
You talk in the book about
de-centering the West
and refocusing attention
on what you've called East East relations.
What you also call Pan-Asianism.
Can you explain what
led you to this approach
and why you think it's important
and how you think it contributes
to the field of Asian studies,
Southeast Asian studies and so on?
- Yes, of course.
So, the late 19th and early 20th century,
is such a dynamic and important
crucial turning point
of knowing global history
and Imperial history,
especially in Southeast Asia history.
And you see throughout this period,
the entire map of Southeast Asia
undergoing quite strong
Imperial consolidation
and experiencing local
resistance at the same time.
And this is true across the entire map.
And it also happens to be
the foundational moment
for Philippine history
because it's the founding
of the Philippine nation
and the eventual nation state.
And you have the first stories
of anti-colonial nationalism
in the late 19th century,
as well as the creation of the first
modern secular Republic in all of Asia
in the form of the first
Philippine Republic
though it's short lived.
And it's also the transition
between the old world,
European Spanish Imperial
power to the new world,
American colonial period,
as well as the emergence of Japan in Asia.
And yet the discussion of
this foundational moment
and Philippine history
treats it as if it took place
in a completely different
part of the world
entirely without mention of Asia at all.
And it sort of underscores what
is a longstanding assumption
within Philippine history
that the Filipino self-image
is historically non-Asians seeing itself
as belonging to the Western hemisphere.
And it seemed to me, frankly,
impossible that the Philippines
would have been divorced
from all of this tumult in Asia,
both Southeast Asia and
East Asia at the time.
And it seemed to me, frankly,
Eurocentric or at best
Imperial to believe that
this would have been the case
that we've been so perfectly
isolated from the rest.
And this is an assumption
that I saw reproduced
outside the specifically
Philippine literature
and also within the larger
Southeast Asian literature.
So I wanted to interrogate this
and I had when I just started at Yale
recently read Cemil Aydin's book on
the Politics of anti-Westernism in Asia.
And this idea about the contestation
of a single Eurocentric world order
was really enlightening to me.
And the idea that Asia was the framework
in which a lot of Asian nationalisms
were arraying themselves
against or would be
Western had Germany
or European hierarchy of races
was a really interesting
thread to me to see
and test whether that was true
in the Philippines too
perhaps in the beginning,
if not so much at the end.
And what I found instead was that
Asia becomes this sort of blank canvas
upon which you can project
your fantasies and fears,
and it can track and index
sort of prevailing paradigm shifts
and was an interesting way to look at
both international vectors
as well as sort of vernacular
vocabularies of power
that co-constituted
ideas of Asia across
the sort of late 19th,
early 20th century.
- Thanks, Nicole.
That's fascinating.
You're a historian
and I know through my
conversations with historians,
that one thing that historians
love to talk about is the archives.
And often these aha moments
kind of emerge in the archive.
And I wondered if you could share with us
a moment where you sort of you decided,
or you were combing through the archive
or something that jumped
out and spoke to you
from the archive that
almost set you on this path
and towards this larger
argument that you're making,
and maybe describe a
figure or a piece of paper
that really just brought it out to you.
- Well, a lot of my
dissertation advisors are here,
so they'll enjoy this.
But I was told when I was first giving
my dissertation perspectives that
the connection between the Philippines
and Pan-Asianism could
be at best a chapter,
but not an entire book.
And so I went off to the archives
having given everyone this
big dissertation perspective about
the intellectual history of
the Philippine revolution,
in which Pan-Asianism was
just one chapter or Asianism,
Asianism Paniism we're one chapter.
And I didn't tell them,
but I went out to set to
prove them wrong, essentially.
And when I was in the archives,
I just found so much that
of the sort of traditional sources
in which all of the references to Asia
and all of the more specific
particular lies, understanding.
So race as a rising
from climate and place,
all these very specific
things had been left aside.
And that was not what
was discussed in all of
the sort of the traditional
works on for Series-A
or beanie
all the big figures
that Philippine history.
So I didn't even have to go that far
within the archives to make my point.
And I basically didn't tell
my advisors what I was doing
until I had written the whole
practically the whole thing.
And I showed them, see, there
is enough material actually,
to do a whole dissertation.
And by then they couldn't argue with me.
So what I presented as a
chapter became the whole work.
(sound fading away)
- No, please go ahead.
- I'm just saying you wanted
something a bit more specific.
So I can talk about one thing,
which was a series of talks about how
Filipinos had forgotten their own songs,
their own poetry,
their own place
to learn the songs and poetry of others
that were not consonant with
their own ways of thinking
and brought about by their climate.
And that was one moment where I saw
a way in which they were the Hills Placedo
and his contemporaries,
were theorizing race as tied to place
and it naturalized base.
And then also made it inalienable
from the actual archipelago,
from the particular
evolutionary thread there,
the climate there.
And I thought that
showed me a way in which
I could start to look at
a more multi-dimensional
understanding of what Asia meant
in Philippine intellectual history
beyond merely a sort of political
social Darwinist, real politic,
transnational solidarity.
I thought that there was a larger,
more sort of complex grounding to Asianism
than just a more narrow Pan-Asianism.
Though that Pan-Asianism
was also a revision
to our understanding of
the Philippine revolution
and Philippine history.
- Thanks, Nicole.
I wanna continue in this
thread a little bit.
There's a theme about the
idea of Southeast Asia
in the introduction to your book,
which I found really fascinating.
And since this is a Brown bag
on Southeast Asian studies,
I thought I'd ask you to
pursue that a little bit
and explain it to the audience.
So one of the funny things
that we as Southeast Asianists do
is we fight for the field
of Southeast Asian studies,
but at the same time,
we constantly tell the
world that Southeast Asia
is an imaginary construction
of Western military
and colonial imaginaries
and all of those things.
And in the book you remind us of that,
but then you also go on to say that
there's something about
the Philippine revolution
that reproduced and constructed
an idea of Southeast Asia
and of Asian-ness inspired
by this sense of shared Malayaness,
which I found to be really fascinating.
And I wondered if you could take some time
to really explain that to the group,
because I think it really
does some important work
for the field of Southeast Asian studies
and how we can imagine Southeast Asia,
not only as a Relic of
Western power politics,
but also from a different vantage point.
- I worried a little bit in the beginning
because I referred to Southeast Asia
sort of anachronistically
because of course the
concept didn't yet exist.
And the historical subjects I look at,
never refer to one another
to their neighbors as Southeast Asians
or fellow Malays or Asians,
but more often they're
referred to by their
sort of colonial overlord.
So it's those under British colonialism,
those under French colonialism.
And I employ Southeast Asia as a heuristic
and conceive of it as
a political construct.
But I think that one of
the things we obtained
by returning to sort of East
East history in this period,
instead of the bilateral framework that
we so often use for this period,
is to see the creation of Southeast Asia
as something other than merely
a by-product of the West.
And you see the
anti-colonial consciousness
and transnational pagination
thinking and engagement
as a historical force that would go on
to help scaffold the self-conscious
region later on.
So for that reason,
I thought it made sense to
anachronistically referred to it.
Yeah.
- Great. Can you explain a little bit
about the idea of Malayness
and how this became so
central to the construction
of new ideas of Philippine identity?
- Yeah, it's a slippery one.
I think even for them,
for at least for the
instructors that I look at.
But it was
one thing that shows first how unstable
the categories of race and
ethnicity were at the time
and also how they could be
used to sort of buttress
Asian nationalisms that were seemingly
insufficient on their own.
So, it becomes very
important to the Philippines
to be counted as Malay
so that they can counter the argument
that they're just an
anarchy of tribes and races
in an archipelago leftover and unmoored,
not part of a larger sort of stage.
And not only that,
they then sort of explore
Japan's Malay origin
and then being able to
claim Japan as Malay,
they get to ride on the
coattails of Japanese power.
Essentially they're much
more nonchalant toward
Japanese power than say the
Chinese are at the time.
And they use this,
their construct of the Malay race
as a way to separate
themselves from the Chinese
and to claim the Japanese.
So it's quite a malleable concept
and they use a lot of the sort of
European folklorist
and anthropological or not
lot of the folklore studies
to basically identify shared traits.
And they look at the linguistic studies,
Dutch linguistics studies,
as well as German to basically
say back to the Europeans,
this a fixed race that we are part of,
and this is their entry point
into a kind of universal
history as they imagine it.
So they can have a place within this
sort of staged history.
So, they take a sort of ranking of racists
and their answer to a
racialized kind of denigration
is through race itself.
And in that way they use it
both positively and defensively.
So, it becomes a defensive kind of
social Darwinist strategy,
a way to be part of something larger
and to buttress your otherwise
localized nationalism
in a larger transnational anti-colonial
and racial solidarity.
And it's also becomes a positive
sort of act of world making.
And they construct the Malay race
to basically have a place
within an Asian landscape
where they don't have
sort of ancient ruins and other things
to specify their nationalism.
So they look outwards.
- I'm gonna ask you to
continue on this thread
just a little bit,
because I would imagine that
for many of the listeners here,
this extension of Malayness to Japan
might come as a surprise.
I think it's possible to imagine
when it looks at the
geography of the cartography,
just the landscape of Southeast Asia
to imagine the ways in
which the Malay constructed
Malay identity and linguistic connections
brings the Philippines
directly into that orbit.
What are some of the ways
in which this was being extended to Japan
and who were some of the key actors
doing this kind of this racialization
and expansion of the
Malay world into Japan?
- So the illustrators who are part
of the propaganda movement,
so sort of educated elite, the straddles
like the national hero, Coursera Resel,
Marianna Ponce, who becomes
the foreign Emissary to Japan
under the first Philippine Republic,
as well as their colleagues,
Isabella de Los Reyes
and other illustrators.
And they sort of do things like
looking at similar folk tales
and myths that the Japanese have,
that the Filipinos also have,
and that their neighbors do.
So they're very crude
sort of extensions and comparisons,
but they try to assert,
I think of kind of fantasy
of shared sort of
race with the Japanese
and at the same time,
as they try to assert this,
it's on the one hand,
a kind of strategy argue to the Spanish
to basically say,
make good on your civilizing mission
and give us the reforms where requesting,
because we have this affinity with Japan
and through the inalienability of place,
it's almost inevitable that
we will join up with them.
And as they arise,
they are a greater threat to you.
So if you want to safeguard
your one of your final global holdings,
give us the reforms we're asking for.
So this is a little tongue in cheek there,
but at the same time,
they also think of it as a bit of a fat
as a sort of dream, right?
And it's like it's an inspiration.
And when you read the writings
where they're claiming
that the Japanese are Malay
usually they actually
just say it like that.
They don't have to prove it.
They just say the Japanese are Malay.
They are noble Malay.
They also construct Japan,
not as this sort of
really familiar entity,
but as this almost kind
of like alternate future
and this alternate future,
not just for the Philippines,
but more globally,
the way that sort of our Socratic
noble titles,
aren't given up in a single breath
and it go voluntarily
the sort kind of discipline
and self-discipline
that they exhibit
they're held up as a thing
apart from history actually,
and quite exceptional and not something
that I quite like in terms of kind.
And so they played both
games at the same time,
or maybe more accurately.
They try to assert a kind of similarity
while at the same time,
what they actually say seems to betray
that they think of Japan
as something very different
and very dissimilar from everything else.
- Interesting.
I wanna explore this connection to Japan
through one of the key
examples that you use
in the middle of the book.
You draw this parallel between
the Philippine revolution
and Vietnamese intellectuals
at the turn of the century,
Fanbo Joe, Fantuchen especially Fanbo Joe
and his travels to Japan
and the dounzu movement.
And I have two questions.
One is I'd like for you,
just to kind of explain
that to the audience, right?
Where you see the parallel.
But the question I have for you is,
to what degree is this a kind of parallel
that's going through Japan,
like at least two parallel crosses.
You have the Philippines and Vietnam,
both experiencing this kind of
engagement with Pan-Asianism
resolve wants to create
a school in Hong Kong.
It's very similar to Fanbo Joe's idea
of the daunzu movement and the
studying in Japan movement.
A parallel that kind of has a vector
through places like Japan and Hong Kong,
or is there actually kind
of cross conversations
that are happening between
people like Fanboy Joe
and Jose resolve as well?
Like, so are there movements across
or do they always go to sort of like
a hub and then radiate outward?
And how do you imagine that Pan-Asianism
sort of working in that way?
- So, we don't have any records of,
for example, Marianna Ponce,
who was in Japan as the
Philippine Emissary,
no records of him having any
meeting with someone which are,
or any of his colleagues in Japan.
Though we have a very long record
of him with Sonia Said,
Yanchi Chan and others.
So unfortunately we don't have that.
But what we do have are
sort of associations,
Spanish associations,
Japan is where we see
that there are Vietnamese
and Siamese
and Filipinos and Koreans all as members.
So, but we don't know the extent to which
that was a fruitful engagement,
how productive it was,
who was speaking to whom
with what kind of regularity or depth.
But we do know that that did exist.
So I do see them as parallel,
though they may have been more connected
than we're able to see currently.
One of the things I think is different
between Vietnam and the Philippines
within this sort of trans nationalization
of Pan Asia,
is that Vietnam,
at least in the way that I conceive a bit,
which is there's the sort of the center
of the pagination discourse,
which is the sort of cynic center
emanating out of Japan and China.
And then there's the periphery.
And most of the traditional
literature discounts,
peripheral Pan Asianism,
seeing it as sort of
only instrumentalizing
Pan-Asianism toward what are ultimately
nationalists priorities.
And so therefore discounting
them as true Pan Asianists.
and I'm trying to sort of make the
peripheral Pan Asianism
legible to the center,
looking at different dimensions to it.
But Vietnam is sort of in between the two,
because it is traditionally
part of the cynic world,
but it is also distinct
and it is part of Southeast Asia.
So it's almost like a stepping stone.
And so it's an interesting way
in which you can test
sort of constructions of Asia,
how far they have to change
and be reinterpreted in
order to be transnationalized
and where that's effective
and where it isn't it
through what methods.
So, it's an interesting comparison
but it is different.
And I think the scales are different.
So for example,
Vietnam doesn't have to
reimagine the Japanese is Molay
by looking at a folk
tale about the tortoise.
It's very different.
And so I guess when you think about
geographies of political affinity,
which is one of the
things I was doing here,
there's less work there,
but at the same time,
I do think that
Vietnam does have strong comparison
to the Philippines
because of the two aspects
of anti-colonialism
and nationalism
and the ways in which those are inflected
by interpretations of social Darwinism,
which then lead both to
strategies of kind of Asianism
and affinities toward an
idea of Asian as solidarity.
But yes, what I would say is that yes,
there do seem to be vectors,
at least from what I
found in the evidence.
And the vectors are mostly cities,
Yokohama,
Tokyo,
Hong Kong
with Singapore and others,
but those are the main Kobe.
Those are the main hubs.
- Fascinating.
Nicole.
This is going to be my last question.
And it's an opportunity for you to sort of
make your statement to
the audience a little bit
about your vision,
about a kind of new Pan-Asian history.
Clearly in addition to
the fine grain analysis and archival work
that you do in the book.
It seems to me that you're
making a bigger contribution,
and I wonder if you might
want to take a moment
and kind of articulate what you see as
what historians of the region
should be doing these days.
You could talk about the
history of the Philippines
or the history of Southeast Asian history.
And then after that,
I'm gonna open it up to questions
from the rest of the audience.
And you can also use the question
to say anything you want, really.
But I'm curious about your
kind of big picture vision.
- It's about 1:30 AM in the morning.
So I (sound fading away)
how eloquent or groundbreaking
this is going to be in any way,
but I do think that one thing
I would like to see Southeast Asians do
is to interrogate the sort of,
not the construct of the region,
but the core sort of tangible
natural reality of the region.
So, sort of the biotic zone that describes
the region from the Mariana's
trench to the Bay of Bengal,
how has that natural zone
helped facilitate the trade
migration exchange activities
and the kind of histories that
I'm talking about into
a self-conscious region.
And yeah, that would be something that
I'd like to see that I don't
have the skills to do myself.
And I guess in terms of contribution
of what my book is doing,
during the peer review process
at Columbia university press
one peer review or an
excellent peer review,
we did so much to push my
thinking to be a lot clearer
and more specific
conceptually,
and to sort of help me follow through
with a lot of my concepts in a way that
I can't articulate right now at this
time in the morning,
but was I was asked and it
annoyed me basically why Asia.
So of course there are histories
that are beyond the kind of
bilateral West with one Asian country
kind of traditional history Scots.
So the Philippines and the US,
the Philippines in Spain,
France, and into China and et cetera.
And they said, of course,
there's a more complex world beyond that.
So why?
So then why Asia beyond that?
And to me to have to explain
why you should be on that,
then you would have to explain
why anywhere beyond that,
it seems to me important enough
that I don't have to think
it through even beyond that.
But when pushed to do so,
one thing that I thought that
my history actually did bear out was
and contribute was to
the history of the rise
of the nation state as the political form
over the course of the 20th century.
And I think that it's an
interesting history because
it shows the ways in which
the social Darwin is framework
of the period amongst
a lot of Asian actors
made a kind of
internationalist dualist kind
of formal experimentation
seemed necessary and natural
that your nationalism should be
buttressed in a larger racial grouping.
And I think that that
racialized interpretation
of the international sphere
will give us a fuller
understanding of modern Asia,
as well as the Asia
within kind of Asianism
and the ways in which
she was constituted both
from and negotiate from
within and without.
And I think that also what
you see in this history
of the nation state is the ways in which
it was globalized a lot
in the hands of Asians,
but it is not nearly derivative of
the Western form and the
Western history though,
that was also under wait.
You can also see through
what I argue as a return to place
the ways which those sort
of enlightenment ideals
and the Western grammar
for the nation could seem
insufficiently specific for as grounds
for anti-colonial nationalism.
And so return to sort of place
as a kind of localized moveable plain,
to counter that very
universal general plane,
is an entry point where you can see
the more specific in particular eyes,
intellectual constructions,
and world making and imaginings
that are underway here to rather than be,
are they just sort of
a transfer in migration
of this Western form of the nation
and the nation state through Asia.
And Southeast Asia in general I think
bedevil's a lot of the assumptions about
the history of the rise
of the nation state.
On the one hand,
it shows as my book does I think
sort of the historical
viability of alternatives
to the nation state on some level,
even if not solely,
but in sort of in concert with,
but at the same time,
it also shows a convergence
on the nation state.
And so it's sort of good
if it doubles both as both
sort of arguments,
the prior argument of the literature,
and then the current
argument of the literature.
And so it's one of the
reasons why I think,
as ever a Southeast Asia,
it needs to be a stronger
part of the way we teach
global history and
research global history,
because it shakes up a
lot of our assumptions.
- I love the way that you
described Southeast Asia
as a place of constant bedeviling,
maybe that we can have that become
the title of an edited volume on
Southeast Asian history,
be bedeviling histories or something.
At this point.
First of all,
thank you for this wonderful
conversation so far,
but at this point I wanna
I'm mindful that we have a broad audience.
We have 50 participants here,
so I'd like to open it up to any questions
from those participating or listening in.
So I'll give people a second
to collect their thoughts.
And if you want to use
the raise hand function,
where you can do those of
you not familiar with zoom.
If you click on participants,
you can find a little button
to raise your hand in there.
Otherwise if that's not working,
just send me a note or signal me somehow.
But I see Michael Vann has his hand up
and then after that John Sidel.
So we'll go with Michael first
after the response with John,
and I'll keep a running list in the check.
Go ahead Michael.
- Okay.
Hello, Nicole.
And thank you all for making this public.
It's really a fabulous opportunity
for those of us around
the world to participate
in these excellent Brown Bag Zoom.
Much thanks.
Nicole I was wondering if
you could say a few words
on how social Darwinism
gets to these thinkers desks
in their minds.
What ways is social Darwinism mediated?
What paths does it take?
I've got a very Western
conception of what that means
and how did it get there?
And could you say a bit more
about what they do with that?
And again thank you all so much.
- So one of the thinkers that
a lot of the people I
studied references Plotkin
and he talks about mutual
aid within a species
as a sort of the tactic
for survival and necessity
for survival.
And this is one of the things that
sort of bridges social Darwinism,
and to punish aneurysm,
is this idea of mutual
help within the species.
More broadly I would say that
the way social Darwinism is
originally theorized in Europe
is as explaining sort of
difference in inequality
within a nation,
but the Asian thinkers that I look at
treated as a way to explain
the difference between
nation States
within the international sphere
and see it as a much
larger international amoral
competition of survival.
And I would say that the way
that it gets to the Filipinos
is through a lot of the
European interlocutors
that they have,
the illustrators that I study
ended up studying in Germany
and in Spain and in France.
And they're very close to
a couple of European
academics specifically
who become part of the
propaganda movement.
Bloomin' traitors is one such academic,
and we have streets named
after him here in Manila.
- Thanks Nicole.
So now we have a question
from John Sidel,
also a Yale alumni.
- Yes, indeed.
Many thanks for the interesting talk.
And just to say,
I'm very interested in reading your book
and it was thanks to the
invitation to join this talk
that I heard about your
book and I've ordered it.
So I haven't read it yet.
So it's based on ignorance of the book
and just the impressions from your talk
that I actually have two questions.
The first is a question about China,
because in your talk,
you seem to suggest that,
to understand the Philippines in Asia,
and to situated it in a
decidedly non-Euro centric way,
we should take seriously,
notions of Pan-Asianism that
we associate with Japan,
at least in the late 19th,
and then certainly in the 20th century.
And also
you talked about the notion of Molay race
and being Molay in some sense.
I'm curious whether in the book,
whether there's mentioned of China,
considering that understandings
of the rise of Indonesia nationalism.
Now tell us how important Kangyue,
Lenchishao,
Sonia Said were
for the make in Indonesia nationalism,
and likewise,
clearly for Vietnam as
was acknowledged earlier.
But in the Philippine case,
I wonder whether that's
there's anything like that
in a country where
just look at your name and think of that
to go look at another Philippine languages
and how much they owe to Hokkien
much more than to Spanish.
And there's already a kind of
DEU Euro centralized account
of the first globalization
and Manila's role in that,
but it involves China.
And so I'm curious about a country that
I think of in some ways
it's just a set of islands
off the coast of Fujian,
that it's just a part of Fujian province
just as mainland Southeast Asia,
just part of Guangdong province,
really at some level.
So that's one question.
The second question is in
terms of these transnational
or cosmopolitan linkages,
if we think of other
parts of Southeast Asia,
we can think of these
cosmopolitan linkages
that are not back to Europe
and to colonial metropoles
as deeply institutionalized
through school systems
that are either part of the Sino sphere,
the four books and the five classics
deeply rooted in what
today we call Vietnam
or they're Islamic in
what today is Indonesia
and other parts of Muslim Southeast Asia.
But in that kind of
more sociological sense
and sort of grounded
in institutional terms,
is it that the Philippines
may have thoughts and ideas
and a discourse at times
that links it to other parts of Asia,
but institutionally
isn't it much weaker in
terms of that kind of,
sociology kind of transnational,
if that's the right word,
a cosmopolitan set of
educational institutions
for the production of knowledge,
that just really aren't
there in the same way,
or are we missing
something in that regard?
- Yeah. Thank you.
This is excellent questions.
So first on China, I mean,
you're absolutely right
that a much larger history
of the Philippines location within
a sort of larger Asia
or pan Asia must include
a longer history that
connects the Philippines to China,
as far back as the second
century D at least,
but in the history that
I'm looking at, though,
there are very strong connections
to Lenchishao and Sonia Said
and they are very key figures within
the sort of pan Asianism in motion,
especially for the figure of
Marianna Pontus specifically.
And they sort of hatch plans
together, the lend money,
try it obtain arms,
and try to enter into an agreement
where they they share use of arms
by lending a shared location
in a certain sort of storage.
So there's a lot of cooperation there.
And I think that at least from
my other points is specifically,
they're very formative
to his understanding
of the role that the Philippines Spain,
within a modern Asia more generally,
and help him sort of feel that
the Philippines is leading the torch
for the Malay race
liberate, the Malay race,
and that he will play this role
in the same way that Sonia Said
will play a certain role.
That said more generally list it's also
an irony that most of
these illustrators are
Chinese Misty source.
And yet they are separating
themselves from China
specifically,
and trying to
claim Japanese
and to separate the sort of
Japanese and Chinese history,
and to put Japan with Southeast Asia,
rather than with East Asia,
it's all really a bit confused,
but in a certain way,
the Chinese illustrators assimilate.
So the Chinese immigrants
to the Philippines
assimilate so well,
and the workings of cases
are so strong there that
they become a separate
group and become Filipinos.
And what the Filipino Strados do
is to sort of try to imitate
the Spanish denigration
of the Chinese.
So they have internalized
a certain kind of hierarchy
for a very long time.
And so in imitation of the Spanish,
they tried to separate themselves
so they can maintain ranking above
the same way that the Spanish do
and sort of ally themselves
with the different kinds of Asia.
They talk about cynic vise,
or with regard to China
and about lying and
about sort of vulgarity.
And then the way that they
construct the Japanese version
of Asia or the Malaysia version of Asia
is very different.
And they always
the illustrators in
the propaganda movement
have lots of essays stressing
the difference between the
Japanese and the Chinese.
And
as to your second question about
the cosmopolitan linkages guests,
you're absolutely right.
I will say first of all that,
I looked at what is
essentially in a sort of elite
version of the same history.
You could take my project apart
and started over and look perhaps only
at merchants at sailors
or at the Muslim South in Mindanao,
and tell a different story.
That is a different story
from the one that I'm telling.
I was concerned with the
kind of really central
and elite founding of
the Philippine nation
and the way in which that's
embedded and reproduced
and the way in which those the regional
and cosmopolitan Asian moorings,
work in a way but are embedded there.
And I wanted to show that
just from the sort of the
more traditional sources
without having to go all around.
I think it's already there,
but you could make it a much stronger
by looking at these other actors.
And I think the Mindanao
story is especially important.
The reason why I would say that
there's sort of this discursive link
with a weaker institutional name,
I think it's because of
American colonization
and the American sort of colonial strategy
of co-opting the elites
to sort of take what was
a very charged Philippine
revolutionary seal
and to channel it into
the sort of tutelage
is very effective.
And at the same time
as the 20th century history rewrites
sort of geographies of
political Fendisuch that
it only becomes increasingly
more advantageous
for the Filipinos to
continue to ally themselves
with the US,
to identify themselves in that way,
depend themselves to the dollar,
to cultivate that side.
And those relationships make it such that,
that's an investment that I think only
they believe redounds to them.
And it's only now that
you're starting to see
some stirrings in a different direction.
However,
I think even looking at
the contemporary scene,
the sort of main state Philippine populace
does not look favorably upon
that kind of reorientation
away from the US
when there was such a strong orientation
for so very long,
and as you know American world power
and sort of capital capitalistic dominance
only roots itself further
the Philippines institutionally
only weds itself deeper.
- Thank you Nicole.
These questions and answers are so fast.
I just have to say I'm
learning so much right now.
So thank you everyone
for the great questions
and wonderful answers too.
I see that Peter Purdue
has a question now,
I think maybe a second round
at the dissertation defense.
- No, I'm not going to give
Nicole a hard time this time.
I mean, I've been reading the
book and really enjoying it.
It's fantastic to see what
once you've made out of it
and over a long period of time,
and you are in a way,
one of the luckiest
dissertation prospectus writers,
since you could take one chapter
and make it into an entire book,
that means you could use those
other potential prospective
chapters to write more books.
You see.
Some people have the opposite problem,
but you came across a goldmine of sources.
And I'm very happy that you did.
I did wanna ask a question about
something because it's not something that
I know anything about.
So it's a really a larger issue
of the relationship between,
let's say the development
of national movements
out of what we might call folk traditions,
or it's called folk millenarianism.
The boxers in China might be one example.
It's a widespread ideal
that you build the national consciousness
from a mass base or an agrarian base say,
or in Japan,
there was folk anthropology
and that's not graphy and so forth.
And you site the book by you Lake Tahoe,
I believe it is.
Renaldo Tahoe where you say that
he argues that the philosophy came from
the full culinary and tradition
of a Philippine society.
And you say you recognized that
this was a needed corrective,
but this book reaffirms the
intellectual relationship
between the reform movement
and the revolution.
So, could you say a little
bit about this shift away.
It seems to me that
seems a larger shift away
from a certain trend to concentrate
on the folk and the peasant
and their local roots of
nationalism revolution toward
a more global intellectual history move.
Why you associate yourself with that move
and what you think it offers?
- Thank you for that question.
Vileto is one of my academic heroes
and he really I think,
corrected the historiography his focus
on those who were only thinking about
the nation state
and the elite actors
who thought about sovereignty
and certain ideas.
And you showed the ways in
which there was a mass movement
that looked at
passion the sort of the SIBO
salvific narrative of Christ,
and use that as a political language
and the ways in which a lot
of the Caterpillar and rights
drew on these ideas.
And a lot of the poetry and songs
to show the ways in which
the full consciousness
sort of constituted a central heart
of the faticoonan.
However,
in the sort of period,
since he published that book,
which I believe is 1979,
there has been a lot of revision
of that understanding which
was seen as in the beginning,
maybe a little bit political,
but then afterwards,
just not born out by the sources,
the watch words of the Kathy Boonen
are the enlightenment sort
of mainstays of Liberty
and truth and freedom and equality.
And they very consciously tried to match
the tenor of their speeches
and their movement to
the international tender
as a way to gain recognition
and acknowledgement
from the people they were fighting against
and to basically position
themselves at that level
and to try to gain acceptance in that way
and to use discursive
strategies that they would
recognize that hopefully recognize
as coming from their own.
So there's been a lot of
literature more recently
that works against
lactose interpretation though.
He did correct some of the
literature sort of blindedness.
And I would say that
what I thought was important
to bear out was that
the revolution which has
basically been looked at
in a solely domestic lens,
and when it's international lines,
it's looked at in terms of
sort of relationship to Europe
in terms of inspiration
or it's internationalized comparatively,
by looking at comparing it
to basically Puerto Rico,
as an example for
also a coordination thing from Spain to US
and has a lot of the sort of the same
kind of raw material, if you will.
And I wanted to
affirm that
the Catuneros thought of the revolution as
international,
and they cheered the rebels in Cuba,
they looked at Japan
and they followed the fates
of their regional neighbors.
And so I wanted to restore that kind of
international dimension.
I also thought it was
very interesting that
when I looked at some of
the millenarian movements
from the 1880s, 1883, 1887,
there were international elements embedded
within those millenarian movements.
And it showed me the sort of
trans nationalized setting
in which ideas of social regeneration
were occurring in the
Philippines at this point.
I opened the book to sort
of accounts of rumors
that were spreading in the Visayas.
One was this millenarian
leader named Kundalini,
who said that
a German steamship would come to announce
that Spain did not own the bee science.
And there is just how we are
God water spout who declared
freedom from Spain
and freed his followers
from having to pay tribute.
And he was able to supposedly
able to summon rain and coins,
which were from America.
And so there are these
international elements
that are at work with
it, fantasies and rumors,
and they occur even amongst
these very localized,
rural millenarian imaginings,
and are not just part of sort of more
cosmopolitan elites who traveled.
And it's one of the reasons
why I sort of don't fetishize
travel because actually there
was a lot of thinking through
and world making happening locally,
that involved international.
And I think it's also an antidote against
sort of overly binary
understandings of local and global,
and the ways in which
a lot of the literature
on anti-colonial nationalism
can be sort of separated into two camps.
One which looks at kind
of transmission ideas,
transactionally, and
cosmopolitanism, and travel,
and another that's looks at
sort of nation and place.
And it's seen as being more conservative.
Whereas here, I think
that the two are sort of
co constituted really, and are entangled.
- Thank you, Nicole.
We have a question from Nati to Figia.
I should also note that it's
getting close to 2:00 AM in
Manila.
So, we shouldn't allow
Nicole the option to end
at what is 1:00 PM for us.
And if we run out of time,
I'm willing to stay,
but we should let Nicole
decide how energy allows.
And so if you have questions
in are afraid that you can't
get them in,
please type them in the chat.
So Nicole has access to them.
Go ahead, Nati.
Thank you for your patience.
- Thank you. And thanks, Nicole.
Both for the discussion on your book.
So I'm a film historian
from Stockholm University.
So the issues I raised is both
connected to issues raised by
Eric, but also to early cinema.
And I would like to hear
your thoughts on this,
because I think it resonates
quite a lot with what you said.
So on the topic of like
Pan-Asian ism in Japan.
So according to newspaper
reports from Singapore
after the screening of Russia
Japanese war films in 1905,
the audience stood up and
applauded after seeing
the Japanese win
due to like a shared sense of Asia
and as serenity colonialness.
I was wondering if it was anything similar
in the Philippines and a similar reception
or thoughts on the Russia Japanese war.
And then the second one is
about this issue of shared
Malayness that we also discussed
in the beginning of this
seminar.
So the first Filipino film company
was and movies formed in 1917.
And I know that is after
your period of time,
but I was wondering,
was it common in the popular
imagination to use Molay in
that sense in the Philippines.
- Thank you for your questions.
So the same moment that you
relate on sort of the research
Japanese war film,
when people standing up and sharing,
we have the same kind of moments
recorded in the Philippines where,
you have sort of university students
writing about it in the papers
and running out and cheering,
but at the same time actually,
whereas the recent Japanese
war was such a inspiration
in Southeast Asia,
actually in both French new
China and the Philippines,
it's the Sino Japanese were
a little bit earlier that actually was
more inspiring and more story
in a really sort of expanded
the political imaginaries.
Because by the time you get
to the Russo-Japanese war,
you start to see Japan acting
more like the Western Imperial
powers than necessarily
the Asian savior to come.
And those at the Vietnamese
and the Filipinos
who had been watching
a little more closely
and I think were a little earlier on in
their anti-colonial sort of nationalisms
and had more direct relationship
with sort of this trans
naturalization upon Asia
saw firsthand the ways in which
Japan's geopolitical
and national priorities
and ambitions could
lead them to collaborate
with powers like France, for example.
And they would extradite
a lot of the Vietnamese would come
under the Damvu movement
to learn directly from Japan.
So the timeline is a little bit different,
I think in the Philippines
and in Vietnam than it is
elsewhere in Southeast Asia.
There's also,
some discussion in the
literature about welfare.
The Russo-Japanese war
was such a big shock
to Asian observers,
and really maybe it was such a big shock
to Western observers to
see an Asian power become
a modern world power.
Whereas actually maybe
for the Thai or the Molay,
it seemed a little bit more natural
that modern power would
emerge in Asia that was Asian,
and that maybe some of the interpretations
and are colored by Western
observers, total shock.
And then
I can't remember now which book it was
if it was Paul brother,
but I think he, he makes an argument,
which I don't ascribe to.
Which is basically that it depended on
the state of development of the different
Southeast Asian nations politically
in terms of how they interpreted
the recent Japanese war.
But I don't ascribe to that,
but I just bring it up
to point to some of the discussions
and literature about the interpretation
and what might be the misinterpretation.
- Sorry about that.
- You're muted Eric.
- It's double muted.
Nicole.
What I was going to ask is how
are you feeling energy wise?
Do you have time for one more question
or would you like to end here.
There's one or two possibilities?
- Yeah.
I think I was feeling worse
actually in the beginning
where I felt that was
just sort of babbling
and not making sense.
And now I'm almost getting
my (sound fading away)
So yeah.
I think maybe two more questions
now that I'm a little bit more coherent.
- So Chang, are you still there?
You had a question and you, yeah.
Go ahead and ask your question
and if Alyssa Paredes is
still has a question,
we'll let her ask otherwise
we'll stop at this.
- Yeah, I think just so much.
Nicole, it' so nice to share
your talk about this in person.
It's 2:00 AM here, as well
as like you sympathize.
I have a question about
world making and worlds and skills.
So, you've talked a lot
about kind of the local also
the global
and from your book,
a what really struck me was
the idea that this space
that we now call Southeast Asia
had a lot of different scales
interacting at the same time.
You've got different
worlds being constructed.
So,
and that really comes through
in the story that you tell.
So I'm curious,
what led you to ground the discussion
in the world that that was grounded
by this idea of Pan Asianism,
rather than all these other worlds
that people were constructing,
the specific subjects
that you are looking at,
what were themselves constructing as well?
- So I think
there were a lot of sort
of discrepant threads
and in the book and
for those here who know what
my dissertation was like,
they were much more discrepant
and much more varied in
the dissertation stuff.
And I think that this construction of Asia
and the idea of Asia was the way in which
I was able to thread
lots of different discussions
and different levels and different actors.
And Asia allowed me to move
outward from the Philippines
to see sort of comparisons.
As I said before,
Asia was the framework in which
a lot of Asian nationalism
sort of arrayed their
nationalism and buttress then
because of the sort of
social Darwinist framework
at the time that were using
and having that as my thread.
And my emphasis allowed me to
bring certain aspects of the
discourse on civilization,
on race,
on place,
on nation,
on belonging
into the four and leave apart others.
And it allowed me to
connect different actors
in different threads through
this one central idea
of the sort of creating the idea of Asia.
But of course, the idea of Asia itself,
once you break it down within
the Philippians itself,
isn't a uniform homogenous
sort of category or space.
And so then all these other scales
come into play because
sometimes when they talk about Asia,
they're talking about the Malays.
Sometimes they're talking about Japan.
Sometimes they're talking
about all of oppressed,
the non-West essentially.
And I found that the kind of
formlessness of Asia itself
was one of the things that
was most captivating because,
it's like an index of the
power structures in the region,
both in terms of fantasies and fears.
- Thank you, Nicole.
So we will conclude with our
final question from Lisa Perez,
who is in a distinguished
line of Philippine scholars
that can connect the both of you
through the Yale program
in Southeast Asian studies.
So it's a fitting way to
have our final question.
Go ahead, Lisa.
- Thanks so much for that. Erik,
it's such a pleasure to
be able to join this group
somewhat promiscuously.
And Nicole, congratulations on this book,
how wonderful.
This is really a wonderful contribution
to the literature
and congratulations for being able to
just like articulate
everything so forcefully,
and so clearly at two
o'clock in the morning
where you are, that's really something.
So I really think that
the idea to the book is
so it's just so inventive.
And I was thinking about it
really speaks to something
that hits close to home.
And I'm an anthropologist.
So I think somewhat
ethnographically about these things.
And it reminded me of
a little encounter that I had
on a tok tok in Chiang Mai in Thailand.
And the like Tokyo driver
was like asking me,
where are you from?
And I was like, Oh,
I'm from the Philippines.
And he was like, Oh, so we're neighbors.
And then at that moment, I was just like,
realized to myself,
like realize that I had never thought
of Thailand as my neighbor.
I never grew up thinking
of Thailand in that way.
So I think, I mean,
that speaks just as much to
my own kind of parochialism
as it does to, I thinkthe
kind of intellectual
intuition that's at the core of the book.
So needless to say,
a lot of us are excited about it.
I just wanted to ask
like somewhat selfishly
in sort of in the spirit
of Erik's question.
Like if you have a vision
for Philippine study is,
Is there like a direction
in Philippine history
or Philippine studies in general that
you would like to see
and feel free to answer it.
I don't mean to make it sound like
a qualifying exam question
or anything like that.
But to answer selfishly,
if you could be just like
if you could decide like where
Philippines studies went,
like where would you take it?
I'm so curious.
- I'm excited to see your
Alisa and thank you for that.
Actually,
this is a good segue to
a history of graphical
intervention that my colleague,
Anthony Medrano and I are
currently undertaking,
which is to return the Philippines
to the region of Southeast Asia,
from which it has been historically
or graphically separated.
So right now
we're co-editing a
special issue of a journal
we haven't submitted yet.
We're still editing of sort
of multidisciplinary works
that look at the Philippines in this vain.
And we have a great
collection of essays so far.
Some which look at sort of
transnational architecture,
others that look at
archeology and linguistics
as well as sort of claims on Saba
and the perennial state of Borneo.
And there's also, I think,
another article on music.
So there are lots of ways you can connect
the Philippines back to Southeast Asia.
There's no one on meter
meteorological, observant Doritos,
and sort of across the region.
So yeah, there are lots of ways.
And what we're trying to do
is to return to the
Philippines different features.
So also if you know of anyone
who's working on anything
within this vein,
please do send me their names.
- [Lisa] Thanks, Nicole.
- Well.
It's the Chair of the council
Southeast Asian studies.
I want to say emphatically welcome,
but we never thought you
left Southeast Asian studies.
I would like to think that
there's a bright future
for the study of the Philippines at Yale.
I want to call out a few
of the undergraduates
who are here today,
or even Mallory, Andrea Lee, Ana Ahler.
And I think there's some other,
I can't see all the names all at once.
But there's a lot of interest
among undergraduates,
Greg Janie,
who's in the history department
in Southeast Asian studies.
And so,
I hope that we can build on this momentum.
And I want to thank you very
much for joining us today
and such a wonderful
talk and conversation.
So everyone,
please join me in thanking Nicole
and we'll allow her to
get back to the nighttime.
- Thank you so much everyone.
It's been like coming home honestly.
The Brown Bag was so
formative to my thinking ideal
And it was so deeply a part of this book.
- Yeah. Thank you so much.
Bye everyone.